[Music]
the first couple who is dancing in the
finale is it's a relief and you know
it's a it's a mixture of I'm so excited
to go to the finals I'm so sad that
Mirai won't be there with me but I think
that this is a time where I am kind of
reflecting on everything BETT Jen and I
have done throughout the competition and
I told her right before we started doing
the press line like I'm so lucky that
she's my partner and I think that she's
just one of the best people I've ever
met and yeah all the pros that are going
to the finals never won a mirror ball so
no matter what there will be a new
professional mirror ball champion I know
I really want to like have one so I can
just have one more closer to Val's you
know it's just it's really more about
that we're both Aries and we both hate
to lose and we like to win so I really
want to win you heard from Val tonight
is he texted he's texted me like 15
times
I haven't texted back yet I need to he's
gonna freak out
[Music]
getting ready for next week for the big
finale for the big finals how are you
gonna raise the bar I mean you keep
pushing this guy you know and he keeps
delivering honestly I want to do
something mind-blowing yeah just crazy
fun out of the box I want people to just
like sit there and not know what hit
them
I mean you are the front-runner how do
you deal with being a front-runner like
is that an added pressure or is I feel
good you know I don't really think about
it I think every time we go into the
rehearsal studio Jenna and I just think
about every time we want to go out and
compete we want to create a moment and I
think that we've been able to create
three awesome in completely different
moments and now we want to make it four
[Music]